thank you I'm very honored to be here to
represent a source ehi which many of you
know is a cooperative agreement between
the American schools of oriental
research and the u.s. Department of
State which is designed to document
protect and preserve the cultural
heritage of Syria and northern Iraq the
program has three major objectives which
are to monitor and report on the crisis
to promote global awareness and to
develop damage mitigation projects to
implement now and post-conflict one of
the primary objectives of a source ehi
is to raise awareness we produce by
weekly reports to document current
incidents that have been folded since
our project began in august 2014 which
utilizes a range of sources including
information from Syrians and Iraqis open
source information from social media and
news outlets and academic publications
and high-resolution satellite imagery in
our first year we dotted 711 heritage
incidents in Syria and another 80 in
Iraq the damage is widespread clustered
around sites exposed to looting and
within proximity to active conflict
zones the aim of our reports is provide
a comprehensive analysis of the Heritage
crisis which also means trying to cut
through the hype our first year our data
does show that the majority of the
damage is the result of looting digging
in combat as you can see here we attempt
to provide a contextualized and nuanced
analysis of the situation on the ground
to better inform policymakers and law
enforcement and much of the sensitive
data cannot be made public this effort
is especially important in our
antiquities trafficking studies the
public discussion regarding this
Integrity's traffic involves ISIL as the
main perpetrator and big-ticket items
being sold in auction houses however our
data show that all belligerents are
involved or complicit in the antiquities
market specifically harvesting I
artifacts for sale this is somewhat
dated map shows the major zones of
control with the green circles
representing looted sites this
circle size denotes the intensity of the
looting given the site sample and so
while looting is ubiquitous the
satellite imagery demonstrates that most
of this is intense in ISIL controlled
areas the corresponding documentary
evidence contextualizes activity is
highly organized to the point of
bureaucratic regulation simply we know
more about ISIL and therefore we talk
about it more and here we see another
map created by supernatural Jews spatial
and analysis analyst who shows the
intensive looting and classical missing
period during oprah's which was
discussed earlier by dr. bewdley and so
while much of the looting did occur
prior to isil's captive capture of the
region once ISIL entered the area our
sources indicate that they acquired many
of the caches of looted antiquities and
sorbed most of the criminal gangs
involved there previously overall the
pattern suggested by the geospatial
evidence points towards for the looting
of sites of classical and Byzantine
periods given the demand for such
material on the markets and the ease for
which the provenance of such material
can be masked or laundered onto the
illicit legal market these sites are
also susceptible to rapid looting using
metal detectors which is a favorite
technique that we've learned and so
Easter C HIV seized information from our
in-country sources on the economics of
the trade and maps the internal market
bureaucracy these photographs which many
of you probably have seen before were
provided to us by many of our sources in
qamishli these images represent just a
sample of the type of objects we are
seeing trafficked most of the material
we are observing our low to the middle
end of the market and this material is
not difficult to find and document given
that dealers are using digital
photographs and social media to reach
prospective buyers all over the world a
source ehi is also tracking the trade
spatially by looking at smuggling routes
that move over types move all types of
contraband ISIL and other terrorist
groups are involved I'll excuse me
around here this is actually tell avi
odd which is located
and a very vulnerable point at the
syrian-turkish border and this indicates
a time period when ISIL had controlled
the area from 2014 too early 2015 and as
you can see here many of the border
breaches and footpaths that resulted in
grew over time as ISIL was smuggling
contraband out of this area into Turkey
and so multiple dollar estimates have
been cited for illicit antiquities
market and what proportion of this
market funds ISIL terror scholars and
pundits and many other colleagues around
associated with a source in each I have
reacted with skepticism at these dollar
amounts asking for the evidence to back
up this claim and rightly so but much of
the information that we receive and this
is just a case study I'm interested to
hear if anyone else is dealing with this
situation we receive it from
confidential in countries sources as
some of these participants are actually
active in illicit activity potentially
working within smuggling organizations
and looting gangs a few were deeply
involved in criminal organizations
including ISIL and we may not even know
some of the real names of our
interlocutor we have photographs
eyewitness accounts documents and
satellite imagery but we cannot publicly
release all these data if we were to do
so it could potentially put our sources
at risk of arrest injury or death and as
researchers were stuck in an impasse
we're in possession of data that would
enlighten these discussions but not at
the expense and safety and well-being of
the vulnerable individuals who took
great risks to inform our work and
unfortunately that were six public data
set to satellite imagery ground-level
photography of looted sites and overland
trafficking routes photographs of
objects in transit social media items on
the open market and material seized by
law enforcement effective and responsive
policy should be informed by evidence
but how do we operating at the
intersection of cultural property and
war crimes reconcile the fact that a
significant subset of data can be cannot
be used as evidence for a public
discourse the hard truth is that even if
we did make this in
information that we have publicly
available we still would not have enough
accurate data to reconstruct the exact
market figures that would satisfy those
concerned with dollars and cents but the
study of antiquities trafficking does
not suffer from a lack of evidence the
data we do have demonstrates the scale
of the problem and we can accurately
state that cultural property crime
contributes to financial benefits and
serves as a valuable mechanism for
social control in the conflict area and
we also know that it's even feasible to
reach even if it were feasible to
reconstruct the dollar amount for each
individual armed non-state actor what
exactly we hope to gain from this figure
perhaps instead we should ask a
different research questions ones focus
on understanding behavioral adaptation
and how to respond to it why did ISIL go
to such great lengths to regulate the
trade of cultural objects and why have
other groups not employed similar
regulatory methods what actors are
acquiring these objects and from where
how are objects moving from the complex
zone to the international market and how
does this practice compared to other
illicit commodities seeking answers to
virtually impossible questions the
dollar figure chimera allows those
vested in with invested interest in
proliferating the markets divert
attention from the facts specifically
that looting and is funding and
proliferating terrorism and a horrifico
ethnicity rearing warfare our challenge
as researchers is to develop and
recommend solutions to these real
humanitarian concerns but the facts that
we see before us thank you so i hope
this spawn some discussion
you